[Music]
the prosecutor's role is to see that
justice is done and justice is served
which allows for the establishment of an
elderly
and vulnerable adult death review board
if anyone thinks they're above the law
with this administration
think again michigan prosecutor peter
lucito
calling for a committee to review
governor gretchen whitmer's deadly
nursing home policy in the state
our next guest lost his sister mary last
year in a michigan nursing home and is
demanding accountability
here to react is anthony messina anthony
welcome to the show thank you for being
with us this morning
our hearts break for you for the loss of
your sister mary
please first tell us a little bit about
mary and how she passed
mary uh you know she entered the nursing
home in about 2014
due to a stroke she had suffered and the
main objective
for her in the nursing home was a
rehabilitation center
hoping that she would come out in time
but unfortunately that was mary's home
and she suffered from time to time from
urinary tract infections
and in turn which the last time i had
saw her was on february 27th her
birthday
of 2020. and at that time she was on a
sedative so
i really didn't get a chance i just
kissed her wished her happy birthday and
that was that
it wasn't until april 16th that she went
back into the hospital
and at that time i was told by the
hospital two days later that she had
tested positive for coca-19
and was entered because of a fever and
that matter of having trouble breathing
and unfortunately my sister then passed
away six days later
that's that's a really horrible thing to
hear um like i said our hearts break for
you we've heard so many stories from
families who've
impacted by these nursing home policies
so
you know my question to you is that
governor cuomo gets a lot of coverage
for what he did in new york with respect
to the nursing homes
other governors around the country that
have been involved in maybe not
identical
but similar policies that had similar
implications don't get
quite so much coverage and there are
concerns that they may not be held
accountable
what do you feel about that in terms of
the parallel between cuomo and whitner
and
do you think there will be
accountability for her
you know i i really don't want to
speculate
on things that i really don't have all
the information i
can say and will say that
you know when my sister passed away
everything was hush hush my sister was
awarded guardian to the state
years ago and there was only limited
information that we could get
our family have spoke together
and what we would like is answers
answers that nobody has received um
also accountability and if it means
forward to liability
if possible ramifications or
things that they feel whoever that may
be that called that
shot to send people back to the nursing
homes when they already knew
that they left the hospital positive
they were supposed to go to neutral
zones in
downtown detroit joe lewis arena or
wherever the hubs were at for them
they did my understanding
was that informed to send them back to
their long-term
facility and when you did that basically
it was a
loaded gun and as you entered
if you had the virus you were anyone
that you came in contact with you might
as well say you fired right at them
and unfortunately my sister yeah and at
least 500
yeah anthony i i hate to interrupt you
we're unfortunately running out of time
but that is the policy in question that
people who had coveted 19 and those who
did not were essentially grouped in the
same spaces
for pretty much a six-month period so
we're hoping for a full and complete
investigation and accountability for
anyone
who played a hand in policy that was
detrimental to people and and we once
again agree with you for the loss of
your sister thank you so much for being
with us this morning